i have to ask you
hardware engineer working on neural
networks now
what's consciousness what the hell is
that thing is that
is that just some little weird quirk of
our particular uh
computing device or is it something
fundamental that we really need to crack
open if we're
to to uh build like good computers
do you ever think about consciousness
like why it feels like something
to be i know it's it's really weird
so yeah i mean
everything about it is weird first it's
a half a second behind reality
right it's a post-hoc narrative about
what happened
you've already done stuff by the time
you're conscious of it
and your consciousness generally is a
single threaded thing but we know your
brain is 10 billion neurons
running some crazy parallel thing
and there's a really big sorting thing
going on there
it also seems to be really reflective in
the sense that
you create a space in your head right
like we don't really see anything right
like photons hit your eyes it gets
turned into signals it goes through
multiple layers the neurons
you know like i'm so curious that you
know that looks glassy and that looks
not glassy
like like how the resolution of your
vision is so high you have to go through
all this processing
yeah where for most of it it looks
nothing like vision
okay like like there's no theater in
your mind
right so we we have a world in our heads
we're literally just isolated behind our
sensors
but we can look at it speculate about it
speculate about alternatives problem
solve
what if you know there's so many things
going on
and that process is lagging reality
and it's single threaded even though the
underlying thing is like
massively parallel so it's so curious
so imagine you're building an ai
computer if you wanted to replicate
humans well you'd have huge arrays of
neural networks and
apparently only six or seven deep which
is hilarious
they don't even remember seven numbers
but i think we can upgrade that a lot
right and then somewhere in there you
would train the network to create
basically the world that you live in
right so
tell stories to itself about the world
that it's perceiving
well create this create the world tell
stories in the world
and then have many dimensions of
you know like sideshows to it like we
have an emotional structure
like we have a biological structure and
that seems hierarchical too like
like if you're hungry it dominates your
thinking if you're mad it dominates your
thinking
like and we don't know if that's
important to consciousness or not but it
certainly disrupts
you know in truths in the consciousness
like so there's lots of structure to
that
and we like to dwell on the past we like
to think about the future we like to
imagine we like to fantasize
right and the somewhat circular
observation of that is the thing we
we call consciousness now she created
the computer system did all things
create world views created future
alternate histories
you know dwelled on past events you know
accurately or semi accurately
you know it's it's consciousness just
spring up like
naturally well would that feel look and
feel conscious to you like do you seem
just like external observers
do you think the thing that looks
conscious is conscious like
do you uh again this is like an
engineering kind of question i think
because
uh like
if we want to engineer consciousness is
it okay to engineer something that just
looks conscious
or is it is there a difference between
well we have all consciousness because
it's a super effective way to manage our
affairs
yeah it's right the social development
yeah well it gives us a planning system
you know we have a huge amount of stuff
like when we're talking
like the reason we can talk really fast
is we're modeling each other a really
high level of detail and consciousness
is required for that right and
well all those components together
manifest consciousness
right so if we make intelligent beings
that we want to interact with that we're
like
you know wondering what they're thinking
you know you know looking forward to
seeing them
you know when they interact with them
they they're interesting surprising
you know fascinating you know they will
probably feel conscious like we do and
we'll we'll perceive them as conscious
i don't know why not but you never know
you